hi everyone
this is professor m science and today i
want to discuss
changing basis in second quantization in
another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics
we know from elementary quantum
mechanics that a very important step
in any problem is to choose a good basis
in which we can write states and
operators because a good basis can
greatly simplify the maths
as you may suspect the same holds true
when we use the second quantization
language
so let's go in second quantization we
can write both states and general
operators in terms of creation
and annihilation operators so all we
really need to be able to change basis
is to figure out how this creation and
annulation operators transform
in the videos on creation and relation
operators which you can find linked in
the description
we start with a single particle basis u
that is orthonormal
and we then define the creation and
annihilation operators by their action
on occupation number states for bosons
the creation operator a ui dagger acting
on an i
gives square root of ni plus 1 and then
the state with ni plus 1
which corresponds to the addition of a
boson to single particle state ui
in this expression i am only explicitly
writing the occupation number
ni that is changed by the operator and
amid
all the other occupation numbers that
are unchanged by aui dagger
to simplify notation in a similar way
the annihilation operator
acts on an i and gives square root of ni
times ni minus 1 so it removes a
particle from single particle state ui
in all these expressions we're working
in the u basis so the occupation
numbers tell us that there are ni
particles in state ui
finally you'll remember that these
operators obey commutation relations to
ensure that bosonic states are totally
symmetric
for fermions we proceed in an analogous
manner we define creation operators by
their action on occupation number states
and we also define annihilation
operators in a similar fashion
fermions are subject to the pauli
exclusion principle so we can only have
a maximum
of one fermion in each single particle
state so the occupation numbers are zero
or one this in turn means that we can
directly use the single particle state
labels u
to describe occupation number states for
fermions and the creation operator c ui
dagger acting on such a state adds a
particle in state ui
which we place at the beginning of the
list and the inhalation operator removes
the particle in state ui
when that state is at the beginning of
the list
for fermions the creation and
annihilation operators obey
anti-commutation relations to ensure
totally anti-symmetric states
now all of these things should be
familiar if you have been following the
video series on second quantization
but if they aren't familiar then make
sure that at least you check the videos
on creation and annihilation operators
of bosons and fermions before you
proceed
if you're continuing then to make
progress in this video we consider a
second
single particle basis v that is again
orthonormal
we then define the corresponding
creation operator for bosons
and the corresponding annihilation
operator
crucially in this case the occupation
numbers refer to the v basis
so that nj is the number of particles in
state
v j we also have the creation operator
for fermions
and the corresponding annihilation
operator and again the nj
which refer to the v basis in this case
can only take values of 0
or 1. the sub-indices in the creation
and relation operators tell us on which
basis states they are defined
so for example this u here tells us that
this operator is defined by its action
on occupation number state in the u
basis
and this v here tells us that this
operator is defined by its action states
in the v
basis although we used n both here
and here it should always be clear which
bases they refer to
so what we have here are the definitions
of creation and annihilation operators
in two different bases u
and v as long as we work in a single
basis then all these definitions are
exactly the same for
any basis the question we want to ask in
this video is what happens when we
change
from one basis to another in second
quantization states and general
operators are written down in terms of
creation
and annihilation operators so figuring
out how to change bases
boils down to figuring out how the
creation and relation operators
transform
between bases
to see how we transform from the u to
the v basis
let's start with creation operators the
action of
a ui dagger on the vacuum state gives a
one particle state which we can write as
ui similarly the action of a
vj dagger on the vacuum state gives a
one particle state which we can write as
vj
i am using the letter a here that we
typically reserve for bosons
but you should convince yourself that
the exact same equations hold for the
fermionic creation operators
let's now write a v j dagger acting on
the vacuum state as equal to v j
again then we insert the identity
operator
now we write down the resolution of the
identity operator in the u basis
this simply forms a bracket which is a
scalar so we can move it to the front
and we get sum over i of the bracket u i
v j
times the k ui we can now use this
relation up here
to rewrite this whole expression as sum
over i u i
v j times the creation operator a ui
dagger
acting on the vacuum state comparing
this initial expression
with this final expression we can write
that a v j
dagger is equal to sum over i of u i v
j a ui dagger this is the transformation
rule between creation operators written
in different bases u
and v this transformation rule
essentially tells us that to go between
the bases
well we need to calculate are these
overlaps between the two sets of basis
states ui
vj as you'll remember from the video on
changing basis in first quantization
this is the exact same quantity we need
in that case
we can now very easily figure out how
the annihilation operators transform by
simply taking the adjoint of the
expression for creation operators
we get a v j is equal to a v j dagger
old dagger we then substitute a v j
dagger with the result up here
to get this we can now move the adjoint
inside
individual sum terms
this is just a scalar so it is equal to
ui vj star
which using the conjugation property of
the scalar product gives vj ui
this is simply the inhalation operator
in the u basis
so putting everything together we get
this
this means that the inhalation operator
avj is equal to the sum over i
of v j u i times the annihilation
operator aui
so this tells us that the neelation
operators also transform
through the overlaps between the two
sets of basis states
the transformation of creation and
annihilation operators between different
bases is
all we need in second quantization
because we can write both states and
general operators in terms of these
in the rest of the video we'll make two
sanity checks and the first one will be
to make sure that the commutation and
anti-commutation relations hold
in any basis if we start with bosons
then in the u basis we have this
commutation relation between the
annihilation
and the creation operators let's write
the equivalent commutator for the
creation and annihilation operators
in the v basis substituting in the
transformation rule for the annihilation
operator up here
we get the commutator of this term
and then using the transformation rule
for the creation operator up here
we get this other term
this bracket and this bracket are just
scalars so we can take them
out of the commutator and we get sum
over i k
of v j ui ukvl
and the commutator of aui and a uk
dagger
we know that the commutator in the u
bases is delta ik
so we can perform the sum over i and get
sum over k
v j uk uk vl
we can now move the sum over k to this
point and we get sum over k
of uk uk which is simply the resolution
of the identity in the u basis
so that overall we get the bracket
between vj and vl
and it of course gives delta j l because
the v basis is orthonormal
therefore if we start with the set of
creation and emulation operators in the
u basis
the transform set in the v basis also
obey the corresponding commutation
relation
we could repeat the exact same exercise
starting with the commutators between
two creation
or two annihilation operators in the u
basis all of which vanish
and we would also get the vanishing of
the commutators in the v
basis and we could repeat the exact same
exercise again
for the anti-commutation relations for
fermionic creation and annihilation
operators
and again we would find that they hold
in all bases
in the second sanity check we'll look at
the transformation of the particle
number operator
n that counts the total number of
particles in the system
in the v basis the total particle number
operator n
is equal to the sum of a j of the single
particle number operators
n v j in turn this can be written out as
sum over j
of a v j dagger a v j
using the transformation for the
creation operator up here
we get some over j of this term
and then using transformation rule for
the annihilation operator up here
we get the second term we can move the
creation operator here
because the term in the middle is just a
scalar and we get this
we can now move the sum over j here and
we get sum over j of the outer product
of v j v
j which is simply the resolution of the
identity and this means that we get sum
over i
k of u i u k a u i dagger
a uk the u basis is orthonormal
so we end up with sum over i a ui dagger
aui
which in turn gives somewhere i of n u i
this shows that the number operator n
has the exact same form in the v basis
as it does in the u basis in turn this
means
that the number of particles is
conserved when we change bases which of
course should be the case
at this stage we can play the same game
with any other operator and the
corresponding transformations just
follow the same derivation here because
we can write
any general operator in second
quantization in terms of creation
and annihilation operators
changing basis in second quantization is
pretty straightforward
we can write both states and general
operators
in terms of creation and annihilation
operators so all we really need to do is
to learn how to change bases for this
creation and annihilation operators
so changing bases is something you'll do
constantly when doing quantum mechanics
and you can find further examples of
that in the videos linked in the
description
and as always if you liked the video or
would like to send me suggestions for
future videos
please subscribe